every three weeks Sabah comes to the
sabrata clinic for chemotherapy it's one
of five clinics for cancer patients in
the country
people from across the West come seeking
treatment but after more than a decade
of conflict and political divisions in
Libya medicine and resources are scarce
the problem is with the medicine it's
it's not available sometimes I can't
afford to buy it in the markets and I
have to skip a chemotherapy session
Muhammad Jama needs chemotherapy every
two weeks he says he drives more than
150 kilometers to get here
I have colon cancer and it has spread to
my liver the government doesn't provide
enough medicine I take three different
types of medication for my chemotherapy
and only one is available now
those who can afford it try to find
medicine privately but it's expensive
my pension is less
dollars a month
my medicine is provided here it costs
more than two thousand dollars a month
I've had to sell almost everything I
have and borrow money from friends and
family
we are a rich country the government can
easily provide us with our medicine
Cancer Clinic is Libya's largest and
best equipped
with 25
000 cancer patients registered in Libya
including more than 6 000 children the
health system has struggled to treat
them many people blame the government no
one from the Tripoli Administration
wanted to comment
the mistrata clinic has 350 beds but
more than 13 300 cancer patients
including children are registered here
unfortunately all public clinics face
many challenges due to the political
divisions unqualified people are put
into senior positions in the Ministries
and are unable to make the necessary
decisions to provide the clinics with
the medication needed to treat the
patients on consistent basis
Libya has Africa's largest reserves of
crude oil and should be a prosperous
country
people here hope its instability can be
overcome
so future Generations won't face the
same hardships Malik trainer Al Jazeera
masrata